still talking be friends it's
complicated when we first got together
we were different people grandpa hey hey
Jimmy this is a Martha and Bethany this
is Mary Poppins meet you more than sort
of bargain on you you're not Barney's
barging my little Walker yeah did you
guys see Spencer Vicki went back in we
gotta go get him
huh what oh you oh my god you're
Spencer's grandfather
are we in Florida Thank You Milo Walker
did I die it turn into some kind of a
small muscular boy scout are we dead it
sure feels good now look at my thighs
okay you have some issues here the game
is busted whose game
I'm Nadia I'm Wonder year
welcome to Jumanji
this next event joke is even more
challenging and remember the future of
Jumanji is in your hands I have one
important question who is Jumanji is
that barbers boy we're gonna go we did
that are we in hell and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's it Ella's to suit your strengths
and weakness's smoldering intensity it's
their stupid face you make huh
what's going on you having a heart
attack
breathe breathe this whole left side is
shutting down
[Music]